[Music]
hello and welcome to chinese whispers
with me cindy yoo every episode i'll be
talking to journalists experts and
long-time china watchers about the
latest in chinese politics society and
more there will be a smattering of
history to catch you up on the
background knowledge and some context
how do the chinese see these issues
almost all listeners will have heard of
the social credit scheme this black
mirror-esque system where you can be
rated on a single school by the
government by your peers and punished
in all areas of your life from not being
able to fly out of the country to not
being able to have first-class seats on
the train and it's all-encompassing
supposedly it's monitoring your every
single move digital and physical
but despite the frequent comparisons
china's reality on the ground with the
social credit scheme is really very
unlike the reporting of course
surveillance exists in the country a lot
of it facial recognition too as
listeners to this podcast might have
heard from a previous episode but a
social credit scheme as conceived of
this black mirror one score is not quite
what is happening to discuss i'm joined
by two experts who spend their working
lives looking at this
i'm joined by jeremy dorm who is a
senior china researcher at the yale law
school and also runs the blog china law
translates which does what it says on
the tin for english-speaking readers who
want to know what's going on in the
chinese legal system and vincent bruce
vincent brucea is a researcher at the
mercator institute for china studies
which is one of the european think tanks
sanctioned by the chinese government
last year they have a new report out
looking at the social credit scheme
so jeremy and vincent welcome to chinese
whispers jeremy to start with can you
tell us what is social credit
uh sure but before i do so i should make
clear that while vincent and i are more
than capable of getting into the weeds
about the legal uh systems that comprise
the social credit system the truth is
that most people in your audience
are likely to be absolutely
disinterested in what the social credit
system is
what they're interested in is hearing
about the mythos
the and the the mythic system that has
been presented in western media and the
idea behind that which is not what the
reality is is the idea that all of the
data trail that we're generating in the
course of our lives online consumer
purchases travel gps positioning uh is
somehow being used to create profiles of
citizens and rank them uh for use by the
government and that is not what social
credit is and usually this is where most
of the audience would tune out um from
my talks the reality of social credit is
that it's by and large an administrative
law system about keeping regulate
keeping records of violations of law
largely by entities not by individuals
but also by individuals
and making those records available both
to other government entities as they
conduct regulation um and also to the
public in case they wanted to say well
this person isn't law abiding this this
business partner isn't law abiding i
might not want to invest too much money
in working with them
and
if you look at the provincial
regulations which are currently the
highest level comprehensive authority on
social credit in advance of a
forthcoming social credit law which will
govern the whole nation and be based on
these most likely what you see is that
social credit is routinely defined as an
entity's compliance with laws
records of entities compliance with laws
now
we can get into if you like more detail
about why there's confusion and what
parts of the system do lend themselves
more to the mythos
but but just to give you an overview
generally what social credit is is
records of compliance with laws
so i'm hoping that our listeners at this
point are not going to tune out because
this is a really important story to get
right even if the reality is actually
pretty boring and nitty-gritty
um politicians in the uk and elsewhere
are still talking about the social
credit scheme in china uh as that kind
of black mirror dystopia that i
described this uh that's they're still
talking about it as a cautionary tale
for the rest of the world vincent can we
just start by you know taking apart
everything that people think that they
know about social credit scheme one by
one and then maybe we can talk about
what it really is um in those in those
pillars so to start with you know this
idea of a single school and
jeremy just hinted that doesn't actually
exist
yes i mean first of all jeremy's
completely correct and i think the idea
of a score there have been some pilots
that have experimented with things that
may resemble perhaps what we're familiar
with
so the most infamous of these pilots was
rongchang and perhaps some of the
listeners actually heard of it
which was
for most chinese people wrongchang is
not on your geography test so to speak
so most people wouldn't have heard of it
in rongchang you could get point
deductions for instance if you would set
up fireworks in prohibited areas or if
you disclose business secrets or if you
organize illegal gambling activities and
what it was was much like a rap sheet or
like a driver's license where you if you
commit a violation you get points and if
you accumulate too many kind of negative
points you could get penalties
but that wasn't really a high-tech
system
at all
it made use of volunteers going around
with notebooks snooping on one another
and then passing these notes onto the
government of rongchang on a monthly
bi-monthly
quarterly basis
um
and in fact the wrong chunk scoring
system also became kind of gradually
controversial in china and at the moment
has been basically
stopped or at least you cannot get
point deductions anymore or you cannot
get penalties for any points deductions
so although the social credit system
still exists uh the idea of live or die
by a score that is mostly incorrect
simply because those have all been
restricted and were based on
just kind of wonky pilots more than
anything else
so so this idea of a pilot is really
interesting because i think um a lot of
the reporting that i saw certainly drew
on as you save in since these specific
examples that are incredibly colorful
but also ultimately not very
representative ron chen i just checked
has a population of less than a million
which for china chinese scales pretty
much nothing i'd certainly never heard
of it before looking at this story
jeremy perhaps we can talk about why at
what what place in the social credit
experiment these pilot schemes take in
the sense that different cities seem to
be doing their own things but also not
all cities have been doing their own
things
yeah i and i think even before going
into that it's necessary to clarify that
there's really different aspects of the
social credit system and treating it as
one system
is really a bit of a misconception and
not a western misconception a chinese
misconception
for historical reasons various programs
have been placed under this umbrella of
social credit but in fact there's quite
distinct programs
i
following my own analysis of all the
primary sources
generally break things down into three
main categories and i think you'll see
where the misconceptions come from and
where wrong chung fits in if i just give
a quick overview of those uh the first
that i was talking about uh in my
opening remarks was is xin yong jinguan
credit regulation and that's where
administrative agencies use the data
that they are collecting to further
regulate entities so if you have a past
record of compliance they might be a
little more relaxed in future
regulations such as in giving new
permits or conducting new inspections if
you have a record of violations they
might give you
more intense scrutiny going forward
and you can restore those records to
change it and that's kind of a common
sense
approach to regulation um i certainly do
it in parenting
things that i know my child has lied to
me about in the past i'm like washing
her hands after going to the toilet i'm
likely to double check to make sure
she's done properly um
the second is jungxing or credit
reporting and what this is is really
credit in the banking sense um
the the what we think of in the in the
u.s when we hear the term uh credit you
know the idea that someone is measuring
your likelihood of repaying loans um
and of you know fulfilling financial
obligations and that's really very
separate than this idea of credit
regulation i mentioned
the third is chongqing which is a more
of a moral type of component and is
about your trustworthiness your
reliability and this is part of the core
socialist values propaganda campaign
where china is trying to really
create its system of values uh they they
often phrase it as in the absence of
religion the party should have its own
value system to instill in the people
now that part is what most of these
local scoring systems were originally
trying to do it was part of an
educational campaign these scores as
vincent mentioned
you're not allowed to punish people just
for a low score you had to be punished
for a violation of the law and the
govern the central authorities made that
clear quite early on that that you can't
have a punishment based solely on credit
you can be punished for violating the
law and they've since gone on to even
make it clear that what information
should be considered
as part of credit needs to be carefully
restricted um so so so wrong chung and
some of these local score projects i
tend to not dismiss
but to distinguish as as largely
toothless
parts of a moral publicity campaign
i would add that some of the scoring
confusion also came from the jungshin
that banking component
because several companies
in an attempt to create reliable credit
lending information again credit in the
sense that we use in banking in in the
us and elsewhere
because so much of china's population is
unbanked or underbanked simply they've
never had a mortgage they've never taken
a loan they don't use credit cards they
don't buy on credit they didn't have a
credit record um something which is a
challenge in any country i'm
experiencing in the u.s having lived for
in china for so many years i have a very
small
credit record in the us and it makes
life very difficult
in that financial component um
so what what they did is they asked
several companies with alternative
sources of information including
the the ali family's sesame credit part
of ant financial
to generate something that they thought
would be a useful lending indicator
again measuring the likelihood that
you'll repay loans based on the data
they had
unfortunately not only did they make a
system that didn't measure that very
well and was based largely on how
frequently you purchased goods on their
platforms um so so creating a conflict
of interest there
but they also
had an overzealous pr department that
went on saying
as many tech companies are prone to we
have more data and insight into
individuals than anyone has ever had in
the history of mankind we can predict
your behavior
and people
widely reported that in the west as
these are test pilots for a national
system
and what they were was they were test
pilots for creating alternative
financial credit regulation systems
which were rejected by the government
and by here the government i'm saying
the p is the people's bank of china um
like i was mentioning that these
distinct components are not only
distinct in their function name they're
distinct by which part of the central
government is driving them uh and and
the financial end tends to be driven by
the people's bank of china that of
course has its own system as well so
jeremy who first associated all of these
things into one
social credit in one sing uh theme
because you've mentioned you know the
pilot cities
the tech companies the central bank you
know in china in the chinese
policy-making sphere were they all seen
as part of this idea of um that's the
same system
yeah i mean this concept of social
credit is an umbrella term uh that
encompasses all of these components and
if you look at the
uh the in now infamous 2014 to 2020 plan
for building a social credit system
you'll see that they all are there the
problem is that the development and
vincent's probably better equipped to go
into detail uh the concept of a social
credit system
in an amorphous form that no one really
knew what was going to turn out to be
actually began many many years earlier
um and the idea that we need to complete
that project carried on but new ideas
kept getting thrown into it so all of
these components heightened regulation
information disclosure about regulatory
action by the government bank the need
to resolve the situation of unbanked and
underbanked citizenry and the perceived
moral crisis of people not having a
value system all of these are real
problems that the government wanted to
have but they kept all getting thrown
under this sort of umbrella term of
social credit uh and there's no reason
for it and frankly i think it confuses
the heck out of people even legal
scholars in china um all the different
terminology there's we now have the
terms of economic credit public credit
trust untrust integrity uh um you know
social credit uh um
and no one is drawing the lines clearly
enough with the
the reason i seize on the three concept
areas that i did of uh credit regulation
credit reporting and credit worthiness
is because those are the more
consistently used terms that do seem to
distinguish themselves from each other
but it but even now in china they're
only slowly starting to tease apart
these systems and decide whether this
even makes sense to be part of one
system um as a final note i should say
that so the picture that i'm getting is
actually quite distinctly
chinese communist party in this
bureaucratic sense not necessarily in
the tech dystopia sense but in the sense
that you have one leader or one policy
um flagship policy at the top then
everyone knows that that's the
fashionable thing to do and everyone
tries to make their own policy agenda
fit into that and to some extent we see
that with the belt and road initiative
as well where all these companies who
would have invested abroad anyway
suddenly doing it under the name of the
belt and road initiative because when
you're in a one-party system um you have
to kind of um you want to please that
kind of overriding policy direction
vincent is that fair to say that that's
what we're seeing you know this umbrella
there's a lot of things under the
umbrella your recent um report on social
credit for example mentioned there were
47 institutions 47 involved with the
system at the moment
yeah and i should add that in a london
system like china that those 47 are then
mirrored at provincial level and another
times 47 at
uh at a profit or kind of sub-provincial
level and it goes on so when we talk
about social credit system and jeremy
you've corrected me on this before and
chinese law in general we're really
talking about a jungle a regulatory
jungle
um
but yes i think we very quickly when we
talk about china when we're also
surrounded by a lot of these headlines
around
you know the amount of power that cg
ping is concentrating it's very easy to
get the impression that there's a linear
process cg pink says x and then simply
all the authorities below see uh start
working with it but that's really not
the case the social credit system
started
really in its first forms in 1999
and at that point it was part financial
credit so indeed the banking sphere but
there were also concerns over for
instance fake products uh the shanzai
that were of course a really big issue
in the early 2000s
when in 2004 2008 there were all these
tainted milk scandals um in 2008 killed
a lot of babies and really caused the
price of trust the authorities very
quickly found a way well you know we're
actually trying to assess whether
someone is trustworthy on this market
well that also applies to food safety
and food security
and that's really how the social credit
system expanded over time
so it's not a linear process but it's
constant fine-tuning local authorities
or central authorities finding a new way
to implement it
and then at some point and this happened
in the most recent years also the
central authority saying well okay it's
nice that we can do everything with it
but if we do everything then ultimately
we end up saying everything about
nothing or nothing about everything
because it just becomes so vague and so
opaque
that we cannot use it anymore
and that is what is happening now is the
chinese authorities after 20 years of
work
are simply saying well we got to take a
step back because this fragmentation
this ever expanding scope is threatening
the main objectives of the social credit
system that we set for ourselves such as
improving market regulation ensuring
that these food safety scandals never
happen again and then rating whether
someone separates their garbage
correctly or not or whether they raise
their dog
or you know those kind of things those
are really secondaries and those are all
the things that are now being cut off
including all the social credit scoring
kind of stories
to create a better system of simply
regulating the market and regulating um
you have to the new socialist market
economy as cgp sees it
when you say cut off um is that the
social credit law that the government is
trying to find finesse for for the near
future
well the social credit system law has
been in the works for many years but we
haven't seen much of it yet
it's actually been a lot of statements
that were issued by agencies under kind
of the national level or under directly
being such as the national reform
commission the state council the
people's bank of china
um just one step down that i've all
clarified well you know this is simply
not the direction that work that we want
to take it in
and most likely um those documents are
paving the way for social credit law
because you cannot implement a law if
everything below it is just a complete
mess
so what we've seen is that in the wake
of these documents that were issued by
the national development reform
commission by the state council a lot of
these provinces have issued also kind of
work plans to then implement those and
that is a process that is
taking a couple years to let all the
provinces kind of work through these
thousands of documents that they've
issued on social credit
pick out the ones that okay well you
know this makes sense and really throw
out all the ones that well you know this
is just too ambiguous this is nonsense
um to kind of put it a little bit more
bluntly and that is the process that is
ongoing now
so jeremy what i'm confused by is where
the social credit system
sits next to the legal system because if
china's already got laws against i don't
know doing having against food safety
all this kind of stuff why do we need a
social credit system
on the other side and you know if it's
not to regulate social behaviors um to
make people better citizens or make
companies more trustworthy
you know what is it doing that the law
can't do it i guess it's my question
and that is exactly the right question
to ask and is in fact the focus of a
series uh going on at uh peking
university right now about the
relationship of credit and the law um
you know so
it should be some obviously we it can't
exist outside of the law um and because
that would undermine all of the legal
progress that china has been struggling
to make for years and put the government
in opposition to the law which is not
where it wants to be um i i s so so what
they're trying to make it i i like to
phrase it as
the social credit system is a sort of
user interface for the law
the important parts of it in relation to
the law are about when violations of law
can be disclosed to the public when it
can be made available to the public so
so in the u.s you know administrative
fines and punishments and even warnings
sometimes
are often made public i understand that
that's not the case in some eu countries
uh where that would be considered part
of corporate privacy uh um but but but
for for us it's government action so we
should have a right to know about it
china is feeling its way through that
when does a violation of law or of
contract which is a legal obligation
becomes something that other entities
should be alerted about
and why should anyone be alerted about
it well for their own business practices
like i was mentioning earlier if you're
about to engage in a project with
another entity
you might like to know if they've
violated the law if they've had quality
sanctions before for the products they
make before you invest uh a lot in them
so they they've decided that that's one
of the functions they want and the so
social credit becomes sort of this like
i say user interface where you're seeing
the law's action uh in a mediated way
through you know display platforms um or
easier to understand uh
listings that the public might get and
you know there are something of now
after many years of a rating for
businesses um but the rating is not a
big data real-time algorithmic driven
analysis of them it is excellent good
fair poor
system uh
of their general legal compliance um and
it is based on the what we call public
credit information which is information
collected by or generated by the
government during normal regulation so
if you received a fine if you were given
a permit uh things like that and so that
is the ranking and that sort of thing
becomes another aspect of this user
interface element that i'm talking about
um where it gets made
interestingly
you know i've talked to people in the
business community about why this system
worries them so much
and they seem to have a much clearer
understanding than the general
overseas population about what it means
for them and they've told me they what
they don't like is that they don't like
that other
administrative agencies and other
citizens will have access to their
records of legal compliance
and and i say well i'm sure you're a
good upstanding business you know what's
the problem and they're like yeah well
we used to know what the cost was of a
violation
uh you know if we violated it we knew
what the fine was we could calculate
that into our business but here if
there's a record it's harder to predict
what the future consequences will be
will other agencies not give us a permit
based on that previous violation um and
so it's harder for them to do business
in that sense i don't have a huge amount
of sympathy for that particular
complaint
so there's a lot to unpack there jeremy
but i just want to clarify firstly and
briefly on your point about this
interface so let's say your company that
you know falls foul of the law because
of something that you've done you've
fabricated i don't know your vaccines or
whatever it is
by interface what you mean is that the
social credit scheme will then give the
government
a language a vocabulary to explain to
the public what that company's problem
was that they were untrustworthy is that
right like what would that listing say
yeah that's part of it so there's two
aspects of the interface um one is
internal to government agencies and one
is external to the public um internally
it's more formalized because the
government can work with itself slightly
better um although always different
right different departments have uh
have their have their own interests and
and response duties and powers so it's
not seamless but basically what it is is
that through a series of mousse and
specific mechanisms for organizing these
records of non-compliance uh the
the data is shared and other agencies
will make commitments
often very
discretionary commitments to take action
against uh people who have been labeled
as untrustworthy by one agency that's a
little obscure without giving a specific
example so let me just
use my my go-to with food safety
basically the food safety regulator
regulators the fda
has its blacklist and its blacklist
isn't just for people who've committed
violations of the law but for people
who've committed repeated violations or
ones that endangered public health and
safety the more serious stuff and those
blacklists are shared with other
agencies
some of whom have agreed to consider
that blacklisting when doing their own
regulatory work so for example if you
run a food safety company and you made
tainted baby milk well that's going to
be criminal probably but you created a
bad food product that risked the health
of people or didn't comply with
standards in your production of food
the securities regulators might look at
your uh proposal to offer corporate
bonds and deny it because they have the
discretion to do that even though it's
not based on a violation in their field
but but they have a large discretion now
some legal scholars in china said they
don't really have that discretion
um so so that's the internal the
external is that through certain
public-facing
largely online platforms
records of serious violations like
blacklisting
um are put online so that you can check
it so if you uh have heard of a new
crypto coin of course that wouldn't
exist in china
because they've stopped that but if you
heard about a new crypto coin that you
were excited about investing in you
could go online and find out oh my god
the people who run this have been
involved in several pyramid schemes in
the past and it's probably not a good
idea
um and and that would be there's no law
making you consider that it's just
they're available
issues in legal terms that are happening
in china right now are around whether
that disclosure itself should be
considered a punishment
and if it's a punishment there's many
more legal procedures that need to be
invoked um in your ability to challenge
that black listing etc so whether
whether that disclosure alone counts as
a new form of punishment is a question
so what i'm getting the image of is that
it's like yelp organized by the
government
and largely with corporate targets
vincent was interested in your report
because you actually point out that the
vast majority of targets for the social
credit scheme are companies and actually
that individuals only
only make up for about 10
which is not what i think the um the
narrative that people have thinking of
which is for each individual has a you
know certain criteria and evaluation but
it's can you talk a little bit about
your corporate the corporate targets
yeah so i mean the most important part
of the social credit system was always
aimed at the market economy right it's
about violations of laws such as food
safety like jeremy has already told us
about but also whether you pay wages to
migrant workers
uh and those kind of things so those are
then also reflected in simply the the
number of companies uh that are targeted
individuals are nonetheless affected in
some way or another for instance if you
do not repay your loan someone can take
you to court and the court can issue an
order that well you know you have to pay
that money back or we'll put you on the
blacklist
but then it still concerns individuals
in their kind of capacity as market
actors because you're taking out a loan
or you're you're signing a contract with
someone
um
and again there have been some of these
things because you've played too many
video games or that you're not
respectful enough to your parents
exactly there have been some cities that
were thinking of that and one of the
reasons is that these problems plaguing
the chinese economy have always been
framed in moral terms right if you
produce faulty food or faulty products
you know that says something about your
morality
um and so
this kind of link between morality and
economic activity was just stretched and
stretched and stretched to the point
where some
people some government officials or some
um
or just some companies just started
thinking well perhaps if you play too
many games
perhaps does that say something about
your miranti or if you separate your
garbage wrong you know maybe
but ultimately all these initiatives
either didn't materialize because let's
be real they are completely ambiguous
and that's also not in the interest of
the chinese government because they want
to regulate the market well
and if they want to surveil you well you
know they have all these other kinds of
tools to do so
um
but so either they simply just didn't
materialize or they have been shut down
later by the central government because
the central government realized well you
guys are just not doing it the right way
um so that is kind of
why also the focus on companies so much
or these individuals in their economic
capacities
perhaps just one comment back to i think
would also jeremy mentioned on
this interface i think it's important to
add that
when the social credit system was
envisioned or when it was designed in
the early 2000s government files in
china were held in dusty drawers
probably no one ever looked at it again
there was a big red stamp on them and
they were just there collecting dust
in 2019 when i still worked in china i
still had to use a fax machine that was
the first time in my life that i ever
saw a fax machine
so just as an indicator it was really
necessary to build up some kind of
government infrastructure
to
you know get all of that data turn it
into an interface and allow that data
sharing either to the public or to the
other agencies within the system and
that was a really important objective
for the social credit system
that is still only partially fulfilled
after well more than 20 years of work
vincent has a quite a good segment to my
next question which is just about how
technologically driven this system is
because there's this idea you know with
black mirror all your shopping data is
monitored uh your physical actions are
monitored by cctv cameras that are
increasingly good at facial recognition
which i've we've talked about jeremy you
and i on this podcast before um add to
that your social media interactions so
it's building an ever more digital
picture of you as an individual and that
is very worrying i think for a lot of
people and fairly so
but you know your fax machine anecdote
just reminded me you know how
technologically advanced is the system
well the basic answer is not at all um
there are a lot of nuances to this but
actually you can go online you can find
documents where
government authorities basically say
what kind of data they are collecting
under the social credit system
those are long lists they are very ugly
um and i'll spare anyone
the torture of having to read through
them
but overall you're dealing with
information like just
an administrative permit like jeremy
already mentioned or any intellectual
property that you've registered
it's just a list of all these
interactions that you've had with the
government
uh so it doesn't include your payment
activities uh on your your taobao or on
alipay or whatnot unless you commit a
violation then the government authority
will probably investigate
and then they put a big stamp on it
upload it and then it becomes
information that goes into the social
credit system
so it's a very human process
uh the information that is collected
under such criticism is very basic for
the most part
um
and just generally speaking there really
isn't a lot of data going into the
system that doesn't mean that the
chinese authorities don't have high
ambitions
so they are indeed looking to apply at
least what they described under
catchphrases as big data and everything
and you see that some cities are slowly
trying to standardize data in such a way
that it can be turned into kind of a
glorified excel sheet and to simply
visualize trends or penalties and these
kinds of things
um but there is it's not tied with you
know facial recognition on the street or
it's not tight with your what you send
on wechat
um beyond simply all the technical
barriers that that may exist to do that
there's also just not a desire
on the government side to go in that
direction what jeremy can i come back to
you on that because
you know vincent just said that there's
not a desire for the government to
collect all of this data and put it all
together i think some people might
disagree with that in that you know we
see so much online censorship so clearly
they're monitoring and they want to mold
public opinion as it appears online um a
lot of chinese people's lives are very
digital i think one billion chinese are
internet literate at the moment and we
know that they spend a lot of time on
wechat
not just talking to family and friends
but making purchases all that kind of
stuff if that kind of data did fall into
the hands of the government or if it was
getting linked to um you know uh
law implementation
that could work very very well right so
except for a lack of um capability
rather than like a lack of desire to do
that does the government ultimately want
to do that
uh
so i don't think the government
ultimately wants to do that um you know
i think this is why the story resonated
with the west though
information technology is really you
know the biggest change to all of our
lives uh in in the last decade and of
course starting before i mean here we
are in i think three different countries
having a zoom discussion you know
something that was inconceivable in my
childhood and even you know pre-pandemic
wasn't common
um
and you know so so big data and this
sort of
unfocused anxiety about it is
everybody's concern you know how much
data does facebook have was i wrong to
tell the eu uh gdpr request that they
want my data say okay to all cookies you
know did that make a difference what you
know what what you know we're all
worried about this in a sort of un
undirected way
um
and when we heard that a country that is
you know routinely labeled as the big
bad um was doing something with big data
and amassing data we said aha there it
is this is what i've been afraid of and
we we all started to look at this system
as this must be what i've been sort of
afraid of but didn't have a name for ah
social credit that's what we call it um
and you know we we had tv and dystopian
fiction about the idea of governments
amassing your data long before this does
china want to do this
have some sort of algorithmic processing
of all of your data probably not i mean
the corporations have a lot of data on
chinese citizens right now and the
government has actually been fairly
protective of citizens personal
information with the new personal
information protection law et cetera
that largely protects your data in terms
of
what other civilian entities can access
and share your data but it also does
limit government access the government
wants to be able to get information once
they have a reason to suspect you they
don't want to profile every single one
of the chinese citizens
it's a lot of work with very little gain
honestly they're not trying to advertise
to us especially on fax machines
it's all facts machines you've made me
feel very old saying you'd never seen
one before
but but but but yeah
one thing that's worth noting as well is
that there is language in social credit
regulation about technology um but but i
i like to use the phrase that it's more
big talk than big data um they'll say
things like
when possible incorporate blockchain
they don't know what that means
they just they're saying you should try
and keep up with tech
so they're giving a few examples of what
current tech are when it comes down to
actual tech regulation like facial
recognition there's some very good
detailed regulations that you can object
to or agree with that are out there
china knows how to talk tech for real
when it wants to talk tech
and you know i primarily am a criminal
procedure person
i looked a lot at police use of
technology in investigations and i can
assure you that should you become the
focus of an investigation yeah they can
get a lot of information but do they
want information on every single
citizen's daily purchases and activities
probably not
um and and the final point i should just
say that the term big data
i mean i i think it's used in a
incoherent way in english
but but in chinese it's even more so
usually what they mean when they say big
data is a lot of information
uh i and i distinguish that from the way
we use it to mean generally when we say
big data what we mean is some data set
that's larger that a human being could
process without a machine assistance
and their big data isn't necessarily
that their big data could just be
records of all corporations getting
permits
and they would call that big data
because there's a lot of corporations um
and in the u.s i think when we hear big
data we think about sort of meta data
analysis
real time faster than a human can
process
and and that just doesn't translate even
though the term is literally the same
what was fascinating to me um for that
discussion that we had jeremy was just
how much um you know the government was
actually keeping companies at arm's
length you know when we talk about
facial recognition there was a lot of
you know citizen law courts where the
government actually sided on the side of
the citizen against a big company trying
to gather that kind of data because i
guess the wider environment is with ccp
which is kind of increasingly suspicious
of the private companies even the
chinese ones um vincent i want to also
talk about the blacklist the punishments
that are happening because that word has
come up quite a few times now and i
think that's one of the concerns that
people have as well that if you
transgress in one part of your life um
then you will be punished in other parts
of your life so one notorious example is
uh children who can't get into schools
because their parents have bad credit
can you talk about that how true is that
um
what do these blacklists the ones that
do exist what do they actually do
one of the leading principles guiding
the social credit system is the idea
that if you're untrustworthy in one
place you should be restricted in all
kinds of ways and jeremy already
illustrated that i think with the
example food safety that if you
transgress laws in that area then
probably that also means that you
shouldn't be trusted with education of
your children or
with some other field that has a high
risk of causing basically severe damage
to society
and so that is the idea of a blacklist
authorities can add someone on a
blacklist and then there will be
subjective punishments in all kinds of
fields
now
to be added to a blacklist you need to
commit a severe violation of laws and
regulations
that doesn't mean that these blacklists
are benign because
we can talk about the law in china and
the law is not always nice in china uh
and i think jeremy you've also put it
very well once that just because it's in
the law doesn't mean it's fair or just
uh we found examples
of citizens being punished over online
comments that they wrote
these happen at the fringes and it's not
some big data kind of system but these
have happened
and the authorities are only slowly
trying to kind of
rain bring back the
poopoo in the range then speak
um on the example of where has that
happened is that being one of these
pilot schemes like wrongchen
uh this happened in anting city again
another city that probably
you wouldn't get on your geography test
which was indeed one of the
demonstration cities so kind of one of
the more advanced
uh the example was uh someone posted
messages about suspected covet 19
patients in a city uh which according to
the record calls the public uproar or at
least a very severe kind of public shock
and that led to the authorities to put
that person on a blacklist
these examples aren't very widespread as
i said but but you know they have
happened and that is because often
chinese law is quite ambiguous in these
kinds of things and how it can be
applied
um
on the example that you'd have mentioned
of
like children not being able to attend
school
apparently that was fake news that i was
completely wrong about myself
if you
if your dad for instance has high debts
and refuses to repay those debts um you
can be barred from attending uh high
paying private schools
uh so like attending like you know these
like one hundred thousand two hundred
thousand
dollars per year uh schools
uh but it's according to the law it
cannot infringe on citizens rights to
attend public education but simply the
idea of you know if you're just too rich
and but you still refuse to pay your
debts then you probably also shouldn't
be sending your kids to these really
high paying schools
well that's probably where the money's
gone um jeremy please
yeah um so so the punishments are
actually why i started looking at social
credit at all uh because like i said my
primary area of research has been the
criminal field and i was worried that
this was becoming a back door to punish
people
um
i i want to say that the punishments
that cross departments
are
very limited and more limited recently
by a national document on what basic
punishment what the basic punishments
for being on blacklists can be
they largely relate to government
discretionary areas things like you
won't be approved for government
benefits the government won't hire you
for government-invested construction
projects um
you know they aren't these sexy
punishments like uh you know not being
allowed to send your kid to schools not
being able to fly first class or on
planes or ride first class trains
almost all of those more exciting
sensational boy china's a weird place
kind of punishments
relate to the supreme people's court's
court blacklist which is really a unique
part
of the uh social credit system and that
one as vincent was saying is for people
who have failed to satisfy legal
judgments against them and in theory
have the ability to do so but are
actively refusing to do it and that's
where the courts
have this unique ability based in law to
punish people uh you know as it was
saying you know we have seen some
strange things of people getting uh
blacklisted for violations of law that
seem to us to be social regulation and
reiki says that is because chinese law
does have more social regulation china's
notion of free speech is notably
different than what many of us are used
to it is a crime to publish certain
things online um you know and beyond the
imminent threat
they call it causing a disturbance in
the public space of cyberspace um
and you know publishing false
information about covid would absolutely
count in that and you can be given a
jail term for that
um so so so that's hardly a social
credit issue as as much as it is the
wrong thing it also have legal issues
like requiring you to visit your parents
or keep in touch with your children
i i haven't seen anyone be you know have
that impact social credit but but it is
in the law which is much more serious
than it being in social credit um but
social credit like i said is a user
interface
sorry it's in the how is that in the law
which one
about parents and being good to your
children as well
uh yeah so the the the recent uh family
education law and law and the protection
of minors requires you to be in contact
and courts can give you uh penalties
such as essentially requiring you to
contact your twice a week uh the law and
the protection of the elderly has
respect for your parent yeah i i mean
the the these these are these sort of
amorphous concepts i um
i have a working paper on china law
translate about the recent reforms in
child law including this uh where
basically the the government is becoming
increasingly willing to regulate the way
you parent your children
um and you know these these are legal
actions that are far more consequence to
regulating morality than social credit
um
but of course social credit can reflect
them because it regulates
violations of law
um so so the the punishments for social
credit have to be based in good i would
definitely infringe that
they actually if you look at the family
you'll probably take this part out but
if they if you look at the family
educational they actually tell you what
the content of your parenting should be
including fostering a love of the party
etc
um
so yeah we probably don't do well um
so the picture that i'm getting from um
for my discussion about why there is so
much um you know
disparity between the myth and the the i
and the reality on the ground for social
credit is that some of the examples are
true
but they're not representative some of
the examples are not true based on
perhaps mistranslations or confusions or
ambiguity that have just been trumped up
but also that chinese law in and of
itself goes further for obvious reasons
than you know the three of us would
experience in the uk the us and germany
respectively and so all of those things
combined together
to create kind of the basis
for for what we think we know about
social credit vince do you think that's
fair
um yeah and plus i think what what
jeremy already said is that we have this
very pervasive image of china on the one
hand the only communist or kind of still
really big authoritarian state that
managed to outlast the end of the cold
war and on the other hand the one that
speaks with very high ambitions of
technology and is now posing a threat to
some of the interests of the united
states and europe or at least that's the
way we see it
so all these things are our own
anxieties about china
uh
they all come together in in this one
picture of the social credit score uh or
as i should say the mythical social
credit score and it's very difficult to
get rid of such a pervasive picture uh
especially when it is only
partially based in reality
only tangentially so and i also want to
pick up on something that jeremy said
earlier which is that even the chinese
are confused by social credit i have to
say i first noticed that something was
wrong with the reporting when i was
speaking to my chinese sources my family
and friends in china um asking them you
know what do you think about this school
isn't it scary and they said what are
you talking about so it's interesting
how much of this story has been
reflected in chinese public opinion
vincent have you seen much of a
conversation about it in that sphere in
china
well i mean generally the most people
don't even know about it
but there have been examples where
chinese internet users got a hang of
what was being reported in the new york
times or in other media
and very quickly
they realized that you know this is not
correct there's got to be something
wrong so some internet users on weibo
they made a parody of the social credit
system not the way it really is but the
way it was per trade in in europe and
beyond
uh and so they made a portal where you
could get your personal social credit
score
um and if you got like 500 points you
know you'd be sent to detention for 40
days if your score dropped to 300 well
you know you'd be sent off to
re-education and if your score dropped
to zero well then you got a pop-up that
you had to schedule your execution days
and it has to be in the next two weeks
jeremy final word to you thank you um i
i would add that the western coverage of
social credit
has hardly been coverage of social
credit at all
it is coverage of us
seen through a mirror of china um
and what i mean by that is is actually
not even metaphoric but quite literal if
you look at the earliest articles on
social credit they barely talk about
china they talk about this could happen
here too they immediately use china as a
way
a hypothetical china as a way of
discussing what their fears are for
their own nation um the american aclu is
one of the earliest offenders and and
the guy mia copeland very quickly and
said i don't really know anything about
the chinese law i'm just
writing about what i heard but this
could really happen here um
and uh the a swedish um
one of the founders of the swedish
pirate party had the same thing he said
this is what's coming for the world
through the use of big data it look
china's really doing it it was always
people using china
as a negative prediction for what could
happen in their own countries
or or in in the global west quotes on
quotes
and i i think it's always been about us
and not about china like i said at the
beginning of our conversation
people don't want to hear about the
social credit system they want to hear
about china's use of data for
surveillance and that's another topic
that i that i do enjoy talking about in
researching um but it's not really
social credit
yeah well that's a great note to end on
jeremy because i can highly recommend
the episode that you and i did um about
facial recognition in china which is
happening and just how pervasive that is
increasingly being so if listeners
haven't heard that and i'm hoping that
there are still listeners at this stage
despite saying that it's not a sexy um
as the story you might have had is um
you know i would highly recommend just
listening to that because i don't think
any of us are saying that surveillance
doesn't exist in china or that is not
technologically driven but just that you
know there are certain differences um
jeremy dorm and vincent bruce thank you
so much for joining chinese whispers
thank you for having us
thank you and joining now is luis
matakis whose report for wired was one
of the first reports i'd seen taking a
look at the gap between the reporting
and the reality on the ground she's a
freelance journalist covering tech and
china louise welcome to chinese whispers
so tell us when did you first realize
there was a problem with the reporting
so i actually think that i was sort of
part of the problem at first so i came
across the social credit system because
i saw all of these reports in the west
about this scary dystopian system that
was you know similar to 1984 was the
comparison that i saw over and over
again and as a tech reporter covering
privacy you know i thought that this was
a fascinating example of some of the
worst case scenarios that people had
been warning about for years um but what
i quickly realized is that it was
actually this thing that had become so
distorted over the course of you know
three or four years and those
misconceptions have just completely
persisted um you know despite sort of
articles like mine trying to correct the
record
yeah and what flagged you up first to
the fact that it wasn't like 1984. so
believe it or not i was actually seeing
studies that were being published in
academic journals that were framing it
as 1984 and it was you know there were
some like sort of ai researchers who
were collecting data about the system
there were like you know social science
studies that were you know talking about
the implications of it um but then i
actually called up jeremy dom and he was
like oh no
uh there's another one of you that is
confused about what is actually going on
here um and that made me realize like oh
maybe this is not what it seems um and
the other thing that i started to notice
is that the researchers who i thought
were you know the most alarmist about
the social credit system did not speak
mandarin they were not basing their
analyses on on-the-ground reporting
everything that they were saying was
secondhand and i started sort of tracing
where this was coming from and i
realized that it kind of all came down
to a few blog posts that were published
around 2015. um one of them was actually
on the american civil liberties union's
website which is a very prominent um you
know human rights organization in the
united states so i think it carried a
lot of weight um but the person who
actually wrote that report doesn't have
any experience in china so it was just
another example of how this really got
distorted by people who don't actually
have any expertise on china
yeah and i see this as a bit of a
cautionary tale for um reporting on
china
in a foreign language outside of the
chinese the cyanosphere i guess because
so many report reporters um and
researchers don't actually speak the
language or they don't have chinese
sources and people to talk to and then
so you get this kind of recycling do you
think that's fair
yeah i think that's completely fair and
i also think it really speaks to the
fact that so many people come to china
reporting with misconceptions and they
come with an idea of what the country is
and what it stands for instead of sort
of listening to what their sources are
telling them and coming with an open
mind you know as an american reporter i
think most americans don't have an
impression about most countries in the
world they don't really know much about
a lot of other places but when i say
that i cover china everybody has an
opinion and it's almost always a
negative one and they come with these
ideas of what this country stands for
and what it's like to live there
and unfortunately i think that that's
only gotten worse during the pandemic
because you know to be fair i think that
some of the chinese government's
policies have been you know particularly
concerning and sort of you know
reinforcing some of the fears that
americans have but also we've lost so
many of these on the ground ties right
there's so many more fewer people who
are going back and forth between the
countries so i think that these
misconceptions are only getting worse um
and the social credit system is just
sort of like the you know canary in the
coal mine like the one sort of example
that won't go away but i think it's
really indicative of this wider issue
that um you know i really want to help
fix in my work and i think the point is
that china you know a lot of the
negative opinions about china and the
reporting about it is fair it is true
there are a lot of things to criticize
about the country and about the
government but we have to still be
accurate in which things that we're
pointing out and sometimes the actual um
you know transgressions and and and
bad things that are happening are not
given air time because of this kind of
imagined or narrative that comes about
and louise i also wanted to get your
opinion on one point that jeremy was
making which was that
there was this motivation um
you know even china aside uh to to be
concerned about where tech is going next
you mentioned those ai reporters saying
this is what we've been warning about so
then in a social credit story china
became a foil for the west for the west
fears and in the way that you know
sci-fi dystopian sci-fi uh does the same
job you know we have to be warned about
these those kind of things that we're
not doing it here and it became less
about china more about our own fears do
you think that's fair
i think it is but what i think is
interesting is that the reverse sort of
becomes true as well so on one hand
people look at china and say oh
uh you know that's that's what could
happen if we don't pass a national
privacy law right like that's what could
happen if we don't reign in facebook and
google or whatever but i think on the
other hand
people
use china to make themselves feel better
so they say oh well we're not as bad as
china or you know
it it's okay to that we are you know uh
repressing these minorities or that
we're you know having these policies
that are really unfair and that are
unjust because well look at what china
is doing right like we're not as bad as
that they're communist we're still a
democracy it's fine so on one hand i
think it's like
it's a warning right but on the other
hand it's a way i think for some people
to feel better about themselves and not
see that these countries have a lot more
in common than maybe we
you know want to admit a lot of the time
and they're also inspired by each other
you know one thing that was really
interesting to me looking at the social
credit system is that you could see in
some of the policy documents that these
chinese regulators were inspired by
things like the credit bureau systems in
the united states and in europe right
like they're looking at these ideas in
other places and figuring out how to
implement them in china they're they
don't you know they don't come out of a
vacuum you know this is we're you know a
global world these things come from
other countries including our own it's
not
us versus them um and i think that
that's another thing that i really
noticed um about this story
luis thank you so much for joining
chinese whispers and thank you for
listening there's a reading list in the
description of this episode for all of
the sources that we've discussed from
vincent jeremy and louise on this
episode i hope you enjoyed it if you've
just come across the podcast on youtube
you can find more episodes through
searching for chinese whispers wherever
you get your podcast from there is a
brilliant backlog of episodes not on
youtube and if you have feedback do
leave a comment below probably
constructive and subscribe to the
spectator's youtube channel so you never
miss any of our spectator tv shows
thanks for watching
[Music]
you